and we're going to start with some
breaking news just into us about the
queen's funeral that is going to be held
on monday let's go straight to our role
correspondence now rhianna mills to get
more on this reality what can you tell
us
plans that the queen during her life was
heavily consulted on and on monday we
will finally see those put into practice
on the streets of central london and
subsequently also move on moving on to
windsor we are going to see the full
military spectacle of a state funeral
her family will again be involved in the
procession there'll be a two-minute
silence to end a funeral service at
westminster abbey that everyone across
the country is going to be asked to be
involved in and eventually the queen
will then be transferred to windsor
where she in many ways be reunited to be
buried with her late husband the duke of
edinburgh so if we run you through some
of the details that we've had through in
literally the last hour the queen's
children are going to keep a vigil at
the lying in state where we currently
saw those pictures of the queen's coffin
that's happening at westminster hall
that vigil by the queen's children so
the king and his three siblings will
take place
on friday night then if we move on to
monday her family are going to be
heavily involved in the funeral
procession which will see the queen's
coffin moved from westminster hall to
westminster abbey for that full state
funeral to end the service there is
going to be a two-minute silence which
the entire congregation of course will
mark but also people across the country
and across the commonwealth are also
being asked to use to pay their respects
the coffin will then be moved from
westminster abbey
through central london taking a very
similar route to the one that we saw it
take yesterday as the queen was moved
from buckingham palace all the way to
westminster hall with the coffin
eventually then from admiralty arch
being moved on by road to windsor castle
where the queen will be involved in a
burial service where she in essence will
be reunited with prince philip in a
private burial service that only the
family will be involved in now in terms
of some of the timings if you're trying
to plan
what you're going to do on monday when
it comes to watching those proceedings
we know that at around 10 35 the coffin
will be moved from westminster hall
around 10 52 it will arrive at
westminster abbey so the service for the
funeral will start at around 11am at
around 11 55 that is when we'll hear the
last post sound and that two minute
silence will then take place
a procession will then set off as i
explained right the way through central
london which will take
the queen's coffin up constitution hill
where
from the gun carriage her coffin will
then be transferred to the state hearse
which of course we saw when she was
moved from raf northhold to buckingham
palace and the car will then transfer
her to windsor
in windsor a more intimate service will
take place at st george's chapel of
course where prince philip's funeral
took place with members of the household
being invited to that as well as members
of family also being involved and
members of family will also be involved
in the procession when it comes to
taking the coffin to
st george's chapel however at the end of
that service the queen's coffin will be
lowered into the vault and at that point
the cameras in a way will be asked to
retreat because at the end of the day at
about 7 30 in the evening there will be
a private burial service
involving the king and members of the
royal family the queen will be buried
alongside the duke of edinburgh in the
king george vi chapel